going up against Elvis the best Motion
Picture top gun Maverick
[Applause]
yeah that puts producer Tom Cruise seen
here in London today in a dog fight to
get his first ever Oscar it holds such a
special place too yeah everything had to
be right it had to be absolutely perfect
and all hail best supporting actress
nominee Angela Bassett are you
guys
in the world did you realize that you
are the first ever nominee from the
Marvel Cinematic Universe that's so I've
been told so I've been told all day I
didn't know that Angela was just spotted
back on set shooting foxes 9-1-1 with a
reported paycheck north of 450 Grand an
episode she remains one of network TV's
highest paid actresses hello are you
sure yes Michelle yo also makes history
as the Academy's first Asian best
actress nominee she's part of today's
Oscars first timers Club joining ride or
die buddy and co-star Jamie Lee Curtis
who got the surprise of her life in her
pajamas this morning hugging hubby
Christopher Guest and listen to a site
kiwi Kwan the best actor nominee phoned
into today as everything everywhere all
at once grabbed the most Oscar nods with
11. oh my God I'm jumping up and down
and I'm screaming so loud
fellow first timer Rihanna song for
wakanda forever is up against Gaga's
from Maverick both squaring off against
this excited 14-time nominee
that's Diane Warren nominated for
Applause sung by Sophia Carson Sophia
was in tears today with Diane but shut
out of the song category Taylor Swift
Rica I'm not alone more snubs no Babylon
love for Brad Pitt or Margot Robbie same
for the woman Kings Viola Davis and
Till's Daniel deadweiler even James
Cameron was shut out of a nod for best
director despite Avatar the way of
waters two billion dollar and Counting
worldwide box office I know I thought
you were extraordinary I cried myself to
sleep the night that I saw your film and
while best actor hopeful Colin Farrell
is a fan Anna De armas's best actress
nod was a surprise so was her competitor
Andrea Riceboro scoring a nom for to
Leslie they're up against vet Kate
Blanchett who's not really into award
shows stop the televised horse race of
it all
[Music]
foreign